are you concerned when certain
judges or people running for d.a
say that accommodations on sentencing
should be made on race does that bother
you
um
who said that i've never heard that
before well people in law schools have
been saying it um i mean students kim
fox in chicago has heavily implied that
communities of color need to be
accommodated for in sentencing and
they've all but done this by just
getting rid of the bail laws that we've
seen
all together right decriminalizing
shoplifting all that please oh i'm
totally okay with that we lock way too
many people up just flat out that's not
so like murder out the next day no not
murder is that shoplifting well i'm just
saying just the bail reform laws in new
mexico and california have been a
disaster but i can't really use it oh
sorry here's here's actually a really
great point um
tough one for me i'm i i agree i think
we lock way too many people up by air on
the side of liberty uh innocent until
proven guilty to take a working-class
individual who is accused of shoplifting
before he's even been proven of guilt
lock him up for several months he loses
his job however what do we see in san
francisco
wave of shoplifting businesses shutting
down because when you don't stop the
crime you get
i guess a lot of crime yeah
it's a tough issue i don't i wanted to
you know let you guys i think we'll
totally disagree on this you first maybe
well i've read a lot on recidivism we
have a fairly high recidivism rate in
this country because really the thing
that causes crime more than anything
else it's not actually poverty it's
income inequality when poor people and
rich people share the same space it
leads to a lot of problems all poor
people together in a neighborhood what
is there to steal poor people and rich
people together in a neighborhood there
you go you have very clean targets and
what's more there are other forms of um
criminality that only really fully
express themselves in the types of
neighborhoods that have a really strong
mix of wealthy and poor i can see that
because again from where i grew up i
lived on the border of a lot of
low-income communities now beverly hills
safest place you could be 3 a.m you want
to take a jog go for it seriously more
maybe oh i don't i haven't been there in
like like five surprise men i'll say
this good luck walking rodeo drive now
well uh uh okay hurston i don't want to
walk rodeo drive during the daylight
okay well i i i agree right yeah yeah
after garcon has had his work in l.a
it's violent violent crime is down since
the 90s we've had a bit of an episode
it's been massive in the last year oh
well covets led to a lot of really weird
exigent factors but defunding the police
with all we haven't defunded the police
anywhere in minneapolis maybe in a
couple places
that's not true minneapolis portland
seattle they've all cut police
260 departments i think it was reported
last year had stripped their phone from
sorry when i when you said defund i
thought i meant like the anarchist
vision of like community policing when
it comes to police funds being stripped
there is a conversation to be had about
the relationship between that and crime
but the crime increase seems to be all
country-wide so i don't know if i'd be
leaning more towards that being a
coveted thing and people being restless
and angry and i don't know aggressive
the thing that i'm trying to say though
is um when i grew up in beverly hills
really really safe free from violent
crime i could walk half a mile though
and the area between rich and poor were
the areas where people had barred
windows every time so when it comes to
criminality there are things that we can
address very fundamentally that will
help everyone there i'm sure there are
restructures to bail laws that we could
do i don't know the particulars it's not
my field um i've also read stuff in
recidivism apparently murder actually
has a very low default recidivist rate
because usually it's done under a very
specific set of heated conditions that
don't actually speak to a person's
character which makes you wonder a lot
about like moral worth and what really
drives a person to do that sort of thing
i think it's something we should look at
critically though i don't have any
really strong database documents the
last thing i want to say because it's
the first point that you brought up is
racial responses to the criminal justice
yes
um yeah i didn't forget i'm actually
going to triple down on this one okay
not only do i think that we should
aggressively look at the ways our
sentencing laws affect and uh
discriminate between black and white
people and hispanic nation uh i think we
should do the same between men and women
because as much as black people are
shafted by the criminal justice system
men are even more if you take a look at
the disproportionate rates of sentencing
relative levels of implicit bias in the
jury women get off with way more than
men mra confirms
so i i mean maybe it's uh uh something
we can all agree on we're guys i think
well so the um the issue though is that
when you remove race it's just a matter
of income or wealth for example if
lebron james goes in front of a jury
he's gonna have the best lawyers
and obviously that's an extreme example
right but o.j simpson had an all-star
team and so the problem is that obama
oh he would also have good oj simpson oh
yeah no sorry
you don't have obama's
kardashian and dershowitz i'm sorry i
would just like to interject that obama
uh extrajudicially assassinated people
and nobody did anything about it so now
that's black privilege but that's a joke
so
but i i think that there's there's an
implication in your argument that i want
to challenge which is that just because
you're poor doesn't mean you commit
crimes i think that's an insult to poor
people right and so i think that if you
automatically assume that now there are
data trends to suggest that but instead
it should be the question of
what are we trying to structurally do or
through incentives
to either punish the people that are
committing crimes and lift people out of
that current level so i think it's a
good talking point
but i don't think it's totally true to
say we have too many people in prison i
think we have the wrong people in prison
let me tell you why real quick we have
more than like any other talk about let
me tell you what the average rapist
serves four years in prison and they're
very likely to rape again
totally different than murder look if
you look if you want funding that goes
to police departments to go towards
actually looking at the rape kits that
they take well well over to a bin 250
000 untested rape kits in the tri-state
area in new york city 250 000 right so
our criminal justice system
you could say it had nefarious
intentions i'll be neutral on that was
very heavy on drugs obviously in the 80s
and 90s
but generally though you cited the
number you said violent crime's been
down since the 90s why do you think that
is it's because we were tough on crime
in the 80s and we had a massive campaign
against it and we had the most peaceful
decade in american history there were a
few factors the viability of broken
windows policing has been
challenged substantially but there are
admittedly some benefits the argument
that i would make is that what you're
really what you're really doing is
you're forestalling the problem uh there
are socioeconomic conditions that
increase criminality not because it
makes people worse people but just
because oftentimes crime isn't some
direct indicator of poor moral conduct
oftentimes it is a crime of necessity or
it is a crime born of the discontent and
the apostles i gotta challenge you on
that what would be a crime of necessity
today with the welfare state that we
have what would possibly be a crime of
necessity um i know for i can at least
speak to personal experience that i knew
uh some people involved in like uh like
they said they would sometimes peddle
drugs and they did it because while they
may have been accounted for by the
welfare state their parents medical
bills weren't not sufficiently not even
close stuff like that now now i could
now maybe legally if that person got
arrested the law says they have to be i
could never morally condemn them they
were trying to save their mom man but i
got to push back on that sure i mean for
sure it's anecdotal but it is so it's
not like a data point
i i never understood this having grown
up on the south side seeing people sell
drugs is not the fastest and easiest way
to make money for someone who's
desperate i mean no joke plasma sales
what would you say i made 140 per hour
playing guitar in front of a a a
baseball field now i understand that
everyone can play guitar or skateboard
or skateboard i knew a guy who said he
just bought t-shirts he went and bought
bulk t-shirts so the people who are
selling drugs they got to buy the drugs
first or they get a loan and you can do
the same thing with socks and then
people go on the side of the road and
sell socks i think the choice of
committing a crime was the choice well
it is well hold on it is always a choice
but we're really talking about is the
limits of determinism here how much do
we choose the things we do you can make
an argument that it's all i mean you're
religious of course so you wouldn't have
this argument but i wouldn't have
anything close to this argument right
from a um a secular perspective you
could make the argument that at the end
of the day the things we do are driven
entirely by the chemical reactions in
our brain and therefore everything that
we do from start to finish is just a
combination of random molecular patterns
and blah blah we don't live our lives
like that obviously i make a choice to
get dressed every day we know how this
works in practice but in practice we are
also the product of our environment and
the fact that for example having a
single parent while growing up
is a pretty strong criminal indicator is
a suggestion that i mean
is it an indicator of a person's
inherent moral worth that they were born
with a single parent probably not so
that statistical difference has to be
accounted for by the inevitable fact
that environmental differences can lead
to harsh outcomes the question is though
do you then create a set of lack of
enforcement to say that we're actually
not going to enforce looting where you
had
an entire article in national public
radio not saying you believe this that
says the case for looting right san
francisco's basically employed this 900
or less they're not going to prosecute
you right videos of them stealing entire
walgreens right not an exaggeration
and then you have and just one other
data point just because of covid
europe's crime rates did not increase
ours did and we had a massive defund
police almost kind of we're going to be
relaxed on criminality type movement and
this is the question right which is how
many excuses or accommodations are we
going to give for crime well we're not
and i i'm just once just to finish is
that my perspective obviously is very
little to none crime's a necessity i
could think of one
maybe two examples where i would make a
moral claim of a crime of necessity and
that would be a revenge crime if someone
murdered your wife or your kid
necessity i'm not saying necessity i'm
saying like a moral accommodation where
i could say i could see where they came
from not necessity let me rephrase that
but the idea that in the welfare state
that we have with the private
philanthropy kind of
generosity we have that shoplifting and
arson and looting
mugging barbara boxer that we should
just say you know it's actually because
the environment you know why you pointed
at me no no i have never mugged barbara
saying that as an example yeah i don't
mean i don't is that was that you in san
francisco where were you no
no i i've gotten stolen from in san
francisco before it was a very fun
experience it was that was back before
youtube too so i couldn't afford to
replace anything okay a lot to respond
to here emil durkheim cool guy dead now
uh thought that crime was sociologically
useful because it shows you where the
antagonisms are between people's wants
and the state's desires so crime takes
place where there's an agitation between
what people are being compelled to do by
whatever their own behavior their
desires and um what the state will allow
you to do so for example uh during a um
um a food shortage you know uh we can
take like ireland during the potato
famine there were um to put it lightly
quite a few cases of theft during that
time because people needed food they
would do anything for it so the crime of
theft in that instance becomes a
sociological indicator of a social need
that isn't being met now today of course
we do have admittedly a fairly weak but
existent welfare state we do have it's
very generous yeah it's a little baby
trillions of dollars every year yeah
for america
i will say you guys want several
thousand dollars in value a year that's
plenty i want a ubi we can go way harder
we do have ubi we just implemented it
with the stimulus no we did no wait hold
on yes the uh tax credits well no that's
got cash checks we have ubi now well
it's not a long-standing program i'll
admit that we've tried ubi and crime
went up well hold on wait wait wait hold
on wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait i don't i need to reject the spirit
checks people commit crimes hold on this
is a spurious correlation okay first of
all you will not be able to find any
analysis that attributes the increase in
crime to people getting their stimulus
changes i'm saying it's the opposite the
argument you're making is that if people
have a sociological need they won't
commit the crime so people got money and
they still committed crimes yeah but it
doesn't always like correspond one to
one like that the reason why people
needed money is because they weren't
getting any money from their jobs
because they couldn't work their jobs so
people were still in a worse well they
also got unemployment remember very
generous unemployment the unemployment
status
600 to 800
right i think it was a week or a month
right it was it's not currently that
runs through and not everyone uh not
everyone is applicable for unemployment
there are a lot of conditions there that
can make that difficult no they were
very generous
we're very we're being we're being very
spurious we're very wonky i'm sorry i
interrupted you i'm just so i just so oh
god where was i something about some
dead guy about how crime
helpful i love dead white guys that's my
i actually don't know if durkheim was
white um so
i'm not pro-crime not pro-criminal here
i'm pro-leniency only insofar as i
believe it helps to lower our recidivism
sometimes it finds that it does for
example you're in prison for 20 years
what do you know you know the inside of
a jail cell the environment in prison is
very bad at encouraging people to get
their life together when they get out
and that's why so many people they get
out of prison they have six months on
the street before they're back in
sometimes it's because they want to go
back in prison's all they know they did
a movie about that um
sorry
shawshank redemption and it was a good
movie it was a great movie yeah which
only serves my point um
but with regards to like being lacks on
crime or whatever there are a couple of
things i think we should all agree to
okay first of all well maybe we wouldn't
drugs is bad we need to stop locking
people up for weed just flat out i think
that drugs in general should be treated
like a medical issue um portugal did
that they decriminalized all drugs so
there's conflicting data on portugal but
fine it's pretty promising so you take
take like heroin nobody wants to be on
heroin okay if you're on heroin in the
fleeting moments you have in between
your little sessions you know
something's up so you treat that like a
medical issue say hey we have government
offices you want to come by
that helps far fewer overdose deaths and
those people they go ahead they become
socially productive bam no crime they
contribute to the economy it just works
better than locking them up i wanted to
say something you mentioned with ubi you
mentioned with the unemployment the
stimulus first of all uh we've actually
had a really hard time hiring for
specific work
like labor stuff because nobody wants to
work and no joke like we've been having
i've been having conversations like
every other day like
can we find some people and it's like we
can't find anybody we got signs up and
down all throughout the area where it's
like come in open interviews
we had uh over 800 uh
flights cancelled due to staffing
shortages
and now we're facing fuel shortages
because it's a trucker shortage
we're we're looking at this uh this
unemployment stimulus thing where
they're doing the 300 bonus another in
the child tax credit which won't be for
everybody and we're seeing a correlation
with massive job openings and
people not taking these jobs
i think it's phenomenal finally the
bargaining power is in the hands of the
workers more so but but but
it's broken like the flights are
shutting down nobody wants the jobs well
then when they do increase the salaries
so it's true the flights are an issue
but here's what they don't tell you in
the in the news briefs so um stock
buybacks something that many companies
now do because of their
decriminalization the airline companies
have spent an anomalous amount of their
profits each year on stock buybacks to
enrich their ceos and shareholders
rather than on hiring more pilots it
seems the issue here is this is a simple
supply demand issue people need to raise
their wages you see these news stories
from time to time where it's like i
raised my wage to 15 an hour and people
showed up and it's like
yeah that is how economics works we had
john schneider papa john on the show and
he told us a story about a pizzeria
where they were paying 35 bucks an hour
to some of their pizza cooks wow bakers
um because that was that was that was a
line he kept trying to find people
nobody would do it he kept raising wages
finally he settled on 35 an hour that
means pizzas are gonna basically more
than double because the wage they were
paying before was like 15 and now
they're over double what they were
paying in labor their labor costs go up
they have no choice but to charge
substantially more for pizza in the
short term within a month or so that
might have an impact on those pizza
makers but the ripple effect is going to
slam into everybody all of a sudden the
contractor can't afford to feed he's
take his family out for dinner he can't
afford to buy the food he wants the you
know because the the base level costs
are going to start going up then the
landlords aren't going to be able to
hire the maintenance crews to fix the
buildings the landlords are on fixed
pricing which they can't change which
then results in
a a brick wall a collapse i just want to
say what we're having right now is an
unprecedented economic shock for a year
nobody worked or very few people worked
and people got used to staying at home
and as the government should it should
have done more but as the government
should it took care of them a little bit
you know we have to ride this out what
are government funds for but riding us
out through common crises uh better this
than war
and um now people are returning to work
and they're realizing work sucks
work sucks everywhere but in this
country compared to maybe some of our
equally developed contemporaries work
really sucks the work culture our rate
of overproductivity the americans more
than any other developed country by the
way we push our workers hard and you
have favorable employment numbers but
you don't have favorable underemployment
numbers there are a lot of people who
have jobs but they have like two to
three part-time jobs they don't get
their schedule for the next month until
like two weeks before the end of the
current one they're constantly worrying
about whether or not they're gonna make
their shifts line up to get enough hours
to get the money they need to pay down
their student debt along with their rent
and everything it sucks and it's
untenable and we are in an era of
unprecedented record profits for ceos so
yes i think the solution to this and
it'll be a rough one that's for sure is
we should normalize higher wages maybe
the solution to 15 an hour was never a
federal mandate maybe it was the
inevitable economic necessity of
incentivizing workers
hard to disagree with a lot of that i
will say that the lockdowns were way too
harsh and intense i will say there is a
fifth amendment argument to be made
though that if the government forces you
to not work then you should be able to
get something in return the government
cannot take something from you
constitutionally and not pay you for it
that's the eminent domain argument right
right which was one of the best
arguments for the stimulus package i
just think the lockdowns were far too
severe and far too intense and really
infringed on people's liberties and
abilities to be able to
um take risks thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you